اطلقت منصه وجود الاسكان في السعوديه حمله
اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري كاول اكتتاب
خيري في العالم عن طريق المحاكاه حيث
تستهدف المنصه من الحمله كبر المانحين من
المؤسسات والافراد والقطاعين العام والخاص
وكذلك الفرد العادي راس مال اكتتابي حمله
جود الاسكان الخيل المشاهدين يبلغ مليار
ريال سعودي وذلك حسب نشره الاصدار مقسم
على مئه مليون سهم بقيمه اسميه لسهم تبلغ
10 ريالات هذا الطرح الخيري مشاهدينا يهدف
الى توفير المسكن لثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اسره شديده الحاجه اسهم وجود مشاهدينا
تعطي حاملها منحه سهم واحد في هيئه
الاوقاف السعوديه مقابل كل عشرتك كل عشره
اكتتب بها المياسه مشاهدينا وفي نشره
اصدارها كشفت بان كبار المانحين وهم
المتبرعون باكثر من خمسه ملايين ريال سيحق
لهم الحصول على تقرير مفصل للاسر التي
استفدت من التبرع هذه الحمله ليست الاولى
لمنصه جود الاسكان حيث سبق وان نجحت في
العوامل الثلاثه الماضيه من خلال حملات
مختلفه الى جمع ما يزيد عن
475 مليون ريال